AJ good morning thanks for joining us
and can you answer the question the
toughest NBA team to watch is who until
they've won three in a row
Dallas has been very difficult to watch
they did win a game last night they won
their third straight but that's been a
tough team for me to watch
Miami well you know Brooklyn is the
toughest come on I mean nice Brooklyn is
the toughest team to watch and that's
yeah that's that is not undescribed that
they were not part of the four teams you
rattled off and tomorrow night's
doubleheader in which we do an ounce the
all-star starters or as we as we know it
at the TNT studios
what time will someone on the internet
announce the starters before we get a
chance to do it live at 7 o'clock what
is the interesting if you get Russell
Westbrook and the rest of the lineup is
Golden State is that good for the NBA no
I don't think that's what it's gonna be
no but no I don't know I don't think and
I don't think that's the way I don't
think that's the way it should shake out
what do you think because it's and it's
different this year because you have the
fan vote the media vote and the player
vote so the fans are 50% this year so if
it stayed with Zaza Pachulia you know as
a starter and I don't know how this is
going to shake out when they do all the
math but I could assure you that that
the media and me and the player voted
not going to have saws on the starting
lineup I wouldn't think so right I
wouldn't think I would know I be on the
next situation we were just talking
about that with Carmelo and Phil and how
it's it's it's like cryptic messages
back and forth here how does this not
mean what topic are you guys gonna dive
into tomorrow night with with the Knicks
and in particular Carmelo and maybe his
future you know I guess that's what we
will what we'll look at from for me is I
mean every time Melo turns around now
nowadays is he's like the first question
is hey how do you respond to what George
Karl says about you how do you respond
to what Charlie Rosen just wrote about
you I mean and not now I guess there
were reports that Phil has asked Carmelo
about you know if he wants to stay in
New York I don't know I mean it's it's
just a mess and every time you think
it's that maybe they're turning a corner
and you look at it and say because I can
recall a few weeks ago Dan looking at
the Knicks winning a few in a row say
don't look now but the Knicks are tied
for fourth tied for a home court in the
first round and now they've they've
drifted back into who knows where so I
don't know that's he he continues to be
this enigma and over one of this one of
the most talented scorers you could ever
find but but outside of that Syracuse
championship there's there's nothing
there to show that he can carry a team
anywhere but Phil Jackson hasn't proven
that he can run a team either oh no
without no but I'm not I'm not giving
him a pass on this at all I just and I
think sometimes it's been a little bit
of a Nero thing where you you you he's
fiddling and you're saying hey speak out
tell us what's going on and and you
don't hear from them so no that's
there's there's plenty of blame to go
around in New York
he's Ernie Johnson from TNT they will
announce the all-star starters unless
somebody else beats them to it and seven
will go in there and check it out now
will we will we will announce the
starters at seven o'clock officially the
starters not somebody's speculation and
I know that you've got three guys there
who were involved in rivalries you know
Shaq and Charles nearly fought in a game
and we yeah they were wrestling it was
it was some big sumo wrestlers well
there was a punch thrown there was a
legit punch thrown but missed okay well
I don't know why Shaq yeah what
constitutes a rivalry now as opposed to
what we grew up with but is is Golden
State Cleveland a rivalry sure I think I
mean I I think it is I think that
there's when there's that little
something in the air when two teams play
I think that kind of
makes it a rivalry and I think you feel
that when Cleveland and Golden State
play and especially when you when you
see that they're their playoff history
and those are the guys that you look at
and say well they're okay these might
guys may be on a collision course again
so yeah yeah it's not like I'm trying to
manufacture one I think there actually
is one there I mean if you tried to tell
me that hey tomorrow night you got a
couple of big-time rivals going at it I
would say no you're trying that's
contrived you know this is this is I
would never say that the game 2 of our
doubleheader between the Clippers and
Timberwolves is a rivalry renewed no but
Golden State and Cleveland yes there is
and I and I think that I think there is
something there and I think if you deny
that I think of players on either side
try to deny it and say it to it
no it's just like playing anybody else
and then that's that's fake I also watch
LeBron and look I said four years I
think he'll end up one of the top five
players of all time
I think statistically he's going to with
his legacies resume but there are times
when he sort of cheapens his legacy when
he's overly dramatic and I don't know
what it is I can't put my finger on oh
if you feel this way it just feels like
the great ones just play and they're not
you know falling down acting
overreacting you had them you feel that
way I think that there was do you think
it was an overreaction by LeBron when
draymond Green hit him the other day
just a little Ernie no I mean serious
serious you think there was you think it
was a foul I think it was a foul I think
there was I think it was a little bit of
both you know I think I think it was a
legitimate shot that green hit him with
but I think yeah I think there's a
little bit of a of an Oscar type of
scenario going on there where you try to
sell it a little bit more and especially
in our thing but you know what I think
LeBron is smart enough to know you know
LeBron you know draymond Green just came
across and hit me with a pretty good
shot and if I sell this enough this may
not just be a flagrant one I think that
goes through your mind to man I think he
knows dreama's history and and so I
think that when
to it and so no I don't think it mminton
it at all I mean you just look at LeBron
James and his body of work and what he's
played through and that kind of thing in
the titles no it doesn't you know
certainly I would wish I wish everybody
in the league would would just play the
game and not try to sell anything but
that's not the way it is anymore and
know it but his legacy to me has not
been cheapened by any theatrics or any
of that stuff
speaking of legacies the pregame with
the Martin Luther King tribute I don't
really have a question for you with it
as much as I just wanted to say it was
just well done it was just right it was
you know you handled it with the the
delicacy you know questions you know it
was just really well done I told people
yesterday if they got a chance to try to
find it if it's on youtube I thought you
and Shaq and Charles and Kenny handled
it extremely well and just wanted to
reach out to you that was the that was
the reason why I wanted to have you on
in the first place would just say that
all right no Dan I appreciate that
because and you know after as many years
as we've been around you you know you do
these shows that are highlight driven
and analysis driven and and that kind of
thing and you welcome an opportunity a
lot of times to kind of branch out and
go somewhere else last year we did it
from the Kings Center down there by
Ebenezer Baptist Church and we had
Bernice King and John Lewis on and this
time we did it from that the National
Center for civil and human rights which
is a tremendous tremendous venue in
downtown Atlanta but to have Hank Thomas
it was a freedom rider who was arrested
when he was 19 years old who got off
that burning bus and Anniston Alabama to
hear his stories I mean it was it was
awesome and and to walk through there
and just a reminisce and think about the
life of dr. King I we loved doing the
show there was we got some really nice
response and it's and it's really nice
of you to say to say what you did to it
we appreciate that also kind of set you
up to say something nice about me
you know kind of to finish the interview
is usually how that works earning your
the greatest day thank you earning
that's it that's all
a good luck with announcing those
all-star starters and I hope that that's
the first place I hear the all-star
starters that's tomorrow night on TNT at
7:00 Eastern well then just unhook your
computer and we'll see Thank You Ernie
it's always a pleasure dan thanks but
that's Ernie Johnson NBA on TNT the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
[Music]